Sí muy buenas noches pues el
expresidente ha llegado aquí a la ciudad
de Nueva York esta tarde como decías en
medio de una gran expectación mediática
y con mucha muchísima seguridad nada más
aterrizar en la pista del aeropuerto de
la guardia en Queens un equipo un varios
coches del servicio secreto han ido a
buscarlo y lo han escoltado hasta su
apartamento en la torre Trump en la
Quinta Avenida Allí se espera que se
reúna con su equipo legal y que pase la
noche Hasta mañana por la mañana se
supone que al mediodía a las 12 del
mediodía saldría de la Torre Trump para
dirigirse aquí al bajo Manhattan a la
Corte Penal para entregarse de manera
voluntaria y que se le lean los cargos
que enfrenta antes de la llegada de
Donald Trump el propio el propio alcalde
de la ciudad arams anunciaba que Nueva
York está perfectamente preparada en
términos de seguridad para hacer frente
a una situación así y advertía a los
seguidores de Trump que se iban a venir
aquí a defenderles se comporten bueno
ustedes ya lo estaba mencionando pero
igual le pregunto qué viene para mañana
cómo se espera que se desarrolle esta
jornada
si mañana va a ser una jornada muy larga
en la que se llevan varios días
preparando pero desde luego estas
últimas 24 o 48 horas la seguridad está
siendo máxima se espera que mañana a
primera hora se empiecen a cerrar las
calles principales cercanas a la Corte
Penal en el bajo Manhattan se han
cancelado varios procesos judiciales la
mayoría de ellos para reducir el
tránsito de personas como te decía se
espera que haya también a primera hora
varias protestas algunas de ellas
encabezadas incluso por congresistas
republicanos que viajarán hasta aquí
para apoyar al expresidente a las doce
del mediodía está previsto que salga de
la Torre Trump se dirija aquí al bajo
Manhattan donde llegaría a la 1 de la
tarde la citación es a las dos y cuarto
en la oficina de la fiscalía que se
encuentra en el mismo edificio de la
Corte Penal y se espera que llegue sin
esposas eso es lo que han acordado sus
abogados además se le tomarán las
huellas dactilares no está claro claro
si se le va a hacer esa foto policial
porque las autoridades temen que se
pueda filtrar a continuación se leerán
los cargos en la planta 15 del edificio
de la Corte Penal frente al juez
colombiano Juan Manuel merchan una
planta que ya está completamente cerrada
desde el viernes allí el mismo hará su
declaración y está previsto que
inmediatamente salga y vuelva a amar al
lago Donde ha anunciado que por la noche
celebrará un evento y dedicará unas
palabras a sus seguidores